can I ask you a question why would you
prefer to be creative and be active with
someone else's business rather than be
still creative and it'll be mind of
being a mother it'll be my business so
being a mother yeah I would still be
doing that but I feel like I would want
something else on my own I wouldn't want
to sort of sit at home I get people like
might want that their husband going out
working and just living with him but at
the same time I would like to have my
own I can't I'm active I can't just sit
at home cook clean it will get boring
but then being a mother doesn't consist
of sitting at home you have to raise
them very active I do know that I'm a
mum but what I'm saying is I like to be
a mom but also have something on the
side I'm not saying I'll do it nine to
five every single day or seven days a
week but I'm saying I would like to have
something so whether it's three days a
week